avant de faire beaucoup parler de lui
benoît canada a passé le week-end
dernier dans cette maison à dijon où il
était venu voir ses parents lesquels
sont abasourdis par cette accusation
d'espionnage à mon fils je sais faire et
vers le haut fonctionnaire
moi je connais pas mais on peut pas
naître un enfant à quelqu'un de en
pâture alors que en effet toujours pas
pourquoi du comment mais quoi
aujourd'hui benoît kane est donc en
garde à vue dans les locaux de la dgse
selon une source judiciaire il est
soupçonné d'être un espion de pyongyang
l'anc est ouverte en mars dernier par le
parquet de paris vise la livraison
d'informations à une puissance étrangère
susceptible de porter atteinte aux
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
pour l'heure la seule chose certaine
c'est son intérêt pour la corée du nord
auteur du livre la corée du nord cet
inconnu et président de l'association
d'amitié franco coréenne
benoît qu'un aider à voyager à de
nombreuses reprises dans la péninsule
coréenne
tant au nord qu'au sud et ce depuis 2005
cela lui a valu d'être parfois invité
sur les plateaux de télévision
sous le titre d'expert en relations
internationales comme ici sur la chaîne
russie a tous des anciens énarques
benoît kennedy occupe un poste de haut
fonctionnaire au sénat il est l'un des
administrateurs de la direction de l'
architecture du patrimoine et des
jardins en charge de la division
administrative et financière
a priori un secteur peu susceptible de
recéder des infos ultrasensible sa garde
à vue peut durer jusqu'à quatre jours